salut à tous et bienvenue dans l'astuce
du mercredi comme tous les mercredis je
vous donne une astuce de mentalist sur
un domaine particulier ou sur un truc à
faire avec votre cerveau rapide à
apprendre rapide à mettre en place
je me suis aperçu que ça faisait très
longtemps que j'avais pas donné une
petite astuce de matches comme ça qu'on
est comme un peu ce qu'on décolle grave
avec les maths sur cette chaîne alors
aujourd'hui je vous apprends à faire une
multiplication de grosses multiplication
très facilement avec un papier un crayon
et l'opération la plus dure que vous
auriez à faire ce serait 9 x 9 mm pour
une opération comme neuf fois niort si
jamais vous avez un doute vous avez fait
une astuce là dessus je vais vous mettre
une fiche par là haut à paraître je vais
vous montrer la méthode de la diagonale
comme son nom l indique l'idée est de
construire des diagonales
alors pour ça on va représenter les
chiffres imaginons 12 x 12 c'est un
exemple très simple pour que vous
puissiez comprendre la méthode
j'écris le premier 12 et je trace des
lignes au niveau de chaque chiffre
j'écris le deuxième hic 12
perpendiculairement et je trace encore
une fois des lignes au niveau de chaque
chiffre est comme ça toutes les lignes
forme des colonnes et des lignes qui se
croisent au niveau de chaque carré je
vais construire des diagonales dans
chaque case une fois qu'on a fait ça la
méthode consiste à multiplier chaque
chiffre par le chiffre en phase donc une
fois 2 une fois une est ici deux fois 2
et 2 fois une et de reporter le résultat
dans les cales en utilisant les deux
parties de diagonale je vous fais voir
c'est beaucoup plus simple une fois
qu'on l'a vu une fois de sa fait 2 donc
j'écris 0202 parce que je suis obligé
d'utiliser cette partie une fois une ça
fait un don j'écris 0 1
je passe ici deux fois deux ça fait 4
donc 04 et 2 x 1 ça fait 2 donc 0 2 une
fois qu'on a rempli entièrement le
tableau il faut maintenant reporté ce
qu'il y à l'intérieur de chaque
diagonale ici on a quatre diagonale la
première la deuxième la troisième et la
quatrième dans la première il ya quatre
jeux mais quatre il ya plusieurs
chiffres il faut tous les additionner
entre eux deux +0 plus de ça nous fait 4
dans la troisième
zéro + 1 + 0 ça nous fait un aidant la
4e ya zéro donc ça ne compte pas le
résultat de 12 x 12 c'est bien 144 je
vous fais un deuxième exemple maintenant
un petit peu plus costaud pour que vous
puissiez bien comprendre la méthode elle
est hyper pratique aujourd'hui on est
combien on est le 26 04 je vais mettre
26 04 fois 2016 sas et du mali alors
d'abord j'écris mon 2604 et je trace
mes colocs sur le côté j'ai écrit mon
2016 et je trace les lignes
souvenez vous une fois qu'on a fait ça
il faut maintenant tracer les diagonales
et à partir de maintenant c'est du
remplissage avec les multiplications
simple deux fois 4 ça fait 8 deux fois 0
ça fait 0 2 x 6 ça fait de 12 dont vous
avez vu j'ai mis les dizaines ici les
unités la 2 x 2 ça nous fait quatre ont
passé la deuxième ligne
ça va nous faire zéro partout puisque 0
x 0 ça fait 0 6 1 et 6 x 2 qui nous font
12 on a rempli tous le tableau il faut
maintenant remporter la somme de chaque
des gones al aussi simplement que sa
première diagonale
à l'intérieur on a quatre deuxièmes
d'agaune al à l'intérieur on a 4 5 6 3
gmg donald à l'intérieur en a 6 4e
diagonale à l'intérieur on a 8 et de 10
et 6 16 et 3 19 donc je mets juste neuf
et je retiens 1 1 et 2 3 et 1 4 ans et
de diagonale la diagonale suivante à
l'intérieur on n'a que deux tons 12,2 et
diagonales suivante intérieur on a cinq
donc 5 ce qui nous fait 5 millions deux
cent quarante 9664 le résultat de 2006
104 x 2016
on avait parlé ensemble de cette astuce
dans les commentaires il ya quelques
semaines donc je me suis dit c'était
plutôt cool de vous faire une vidéo ce
serait beaucoup plus claire à comprendre
j'espère aussi que ça pourrait vous
servir un jour un moment donné vous
serez en galère vous avez un gros
calculs à faire une grosse
multiplication au frère et il ya la
technique des diagonales
si les astuces du mercredi vous plaisent
n'oubliez pas qu'en plus le samedi à des
master class est beaucoup plus
consistant et c'est toujours à base de
mentalisme si cette vidéo vous a plu si
ce style de vidéos vous plaisent vous
pourriez me faire savoir en laissant un
excuse moi tu vois juste ici voilà c'est
un pouce en l'air
merci à vous tous d'être là et de suivre
la chaîne merci beaucoup à ceux qui sous
titres ces vidéos et si vous venez juste
d'arriver suite à un partage n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner
le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao